clarissa ward you may have come across
her coverage of afghanistan when the u.s
was withdrawing its uh
troops and people from there she's a
conflict reporter who has she speaks
seven different languages she's
completed multiple assignments in syria
egypt russia china lebanon iraq and
afghanistan um she basically like you've
seen her interview taliban fighters
you've seen her go and report from the
taliban like zone way before i think
this was in 2019 or 2018 um and she says
i appear calm but that doesn't mean i am
calm i don't panic because you can't
panic in those situations if you're
someone who panics then you probably
should be doing a different job because
it will get you into more trouble but it
doesn't mean i'm calm on the inside
that's just the way i deal with fear i
get quiet and very focused she started
her career at fox news
covering the overnight desk the
overnight assignment desk and then
she volunteered for a job nobody else
wanted which was to go to baghdad
and then from there she moved on to i
think she's been at cbs um abc and now
cnn um but yeah she she basically sees
herself as a translator between worlds
who helps remind the viewer that beyond
the geopolitics of power and the
brutality of war and the clashes of
cultures people are just people and the
coolest thing or the coolest thing the
most interesting thing to me watching
her coverage of afghanistan is that you
were seeing the biden administration a
lot of the people in the u.s telling
their citizens one thing about what was
going on there and she was literally
reporting from the ground talking to the
people who couldn't get into the airport
whose visas were being denied and like
their green cards weren't being accepted
so um i just think the reality as always
on the ground is very different from the
high brow political rhetoric we hear for
people to really hammer this point home
let's pull up the pictures of clarissa
here we've got a number of pictures of
her essentially surrounded by the
taliban on multiple occasions and
remember i mean look at this photo this
is
nuts
this is when she went there yeah this is
a woman who is talking to a group of
people who
hang their hat on the fact that women do
not have the same rights as men
right and she's sitting there or
surrounded by armed men
of the taliban if you then go down and
you look there's we've got a couple of
other uh other photos here we've got uh
another one where she's doing her
reporting and they're just constantly in
the background they're constantly
everywhere and it's not like she's
traveling with the us army protecting
her we've got another photo where it's
just her and the cameraman for the most
part literally they're doing their job
but it's not like they've got tons of
security around them they're just
standing on the street in uh what is a
war zone where
many american soldiers would not feel
comfortable doing this but this woman's
sitting there doing it then on top of it
we've got uh two more photos one where
again she's surrounded by the taliban uh
and there's definitely an element of
where uh the taliban or other types of
folks uh are interested in letting her
do this because it allows for her to
tell both sides of a story both their
perspective and the perspective of
people who are there locally uh but it's
still incredibly dangerous and i think
plenty uh there's a story at one point
where like somebody basically like had
like a whip or something and they didn't
hit her with it but uh they basically
threatened her i think they like kind of
threatened the cameraman and it was like
a chain with a padlock on it and he was
whipping it around but um the one thing
about clarissa that i find really
interesting is she grew up
in a very wealthy family she she had
like 11 nannies on the upper east side
by the time she was eight years old she
went to elite british boarding schools
but then she realized it was 9 11 she
was in college and it opened her eyes to
like hold on um the rest of the world
doesn't think of the united states the
same way that we americans see each
other um and so she started learning she
had a love for languages so she started
learning languages and that kind of
letter to
being a foreign correspondent she knows
english french italian spanish russian
arabic and mandarin chinese and she says
that that's actually really helpful
because when she's in those situations
she also like knows the dialect of
certain places
and it helps her
recognize when a situation is getting a
bit dodgy and when to leave and get
herself to safety rather she doesn't
rely on translators which is very rare
for these reporters joe john what do you
guys think about this yeah i mean she's
obviously got a lot of courage right
she's sitting there on the ground uh and
doing things that i think a lot of other
people would not only find scary but
refuse to do and she's obviously super
impressive like the language thing is
one that that stuff always blows my mind
when you're able to go back and forth
between six seven eight different
languages that's like a different type
of uh intelligence in my mind
i i definitely could never do that yeah
that that to me is like try learning
another language and most people find
just learning one other one hard being
able to do it and then also the
difference between like learning spanish
which is pretty similar to uh english
and mandarin in arabic yeah arabic like
nowhere i tried like spanish and that
was tough i think they tried arabic well
i tried i tried spanish i tried
one thing that was a cool thing on
languages that i forget who told me was
when you group them by uh how their
sentences are structured like
vocabulary's vocabulary you have to know
the vocabulary and how to say it um how
to spell it whatever but when you group
them by structure of the sentences right
so in spanish and english the difference
is like you don't say
the blue vase you say the vase that is
blue right um so spanish and i believe
french are very similar because they're
romance languages english and i think
german are technically considered
similar because of the way they
structure their sentences and when
someone told me that i thought that was
really interesting it helps it basically
makes it easier for you to learn
different languages there's a science to
learning different languages like
literally whether it's the cia the
defense department etc they teach people
how to learn other languages and they
have it down to the science of hey
here's how we quickly get you up to
speed in six weeks or 12 weeks or
whatever so it's possible just for the
average person who's doing it for like
an hour a day or something very
difficult and obviously the other best
way to do is just go immerse yourself in
the thing you want to learn spanish go
move to a country in south or central
america or go move to spain and don't
speak any english for six months like
you'll pick up stuff yeah i know a guy
that came uh
one of these a guy that i know he moved
from brazil and he didn't know any
english or whatever and he moved i think
at the time he was like uh 12 13 or 14
like you know young teenager um and he
essentially said like all i did was just
immerse myself in the culture like i
watched movies in english i did
everything in english uh and over time
you obviously pick it up and you start
to learn a little more but it becomes
easier when you start to just realize
that everything you do uh is in that new
language also another fun fact about
clarissa is she's married to a guy who
was a german count i think his name was
like philip vaughn like dracula
why
he the count no is now what dracula is
his name is phillip von bernstorf and
he's also a fund manager um so what do
you think they talk about like how do
you think yeah it's called count dracula
just so we're all clear go ahead
i knew i knew that guy her husband is
not dracula guys um
but uh but like okay imagine being
married to a woman who does this for a
living and you being like a fund manager
like you're immediately the most boring
person in the room
of course what what are the biggest
things you you spent i don't know how
long hopefully i'm not saying anything
that i'm not supposed to say but you
spent
weeks at this point reading everything
you could find on her watching as much
uh content about her as you could
interviews uh everything that she's ever
put out on the internet in terms of like
her process et cetera what were the big
takeaways for you around her um like
what's driving her to do this and what
did you take away i one of the most
interesting things is that um
she draws a very strong line as a
foreign correspondent uh between
reporting and activism so she's like
there's so many instances where you're
like oh my god like we gotta help these
people we gotta do something for these
people where you see a lot of suffering
but she's like you know in order to do
your job you have to be somewhat neutral
and not be an activist but she says that
by telling these people stories
she hopes that you know it inspires
people to do certain things etc but her
job is a storyteller rather than an
activist hey guys bang bang thanks so
much for watching the best business show
today and don't forget to check out our
partner sofi they make all this possible
they're a super app that lets you save
spend borrow earn and invest all from
one single platform and if you go there
today and you sign up for a sofi invest
account you can get between five dollars
and a thousand bucks for free from sofa
not everyone's obviously gonna get a
thousand dollars but everyone gets
something don't say that i never did
anything for you go check them out at
sofi.com
download the app and go ahead and open
an account
pomp and make sure you come back and
watch more the best business show we're
going to build the biggest business show
in the world and we need your help